my talk of the table is about a pioneer
named clifford alexander jr sorry to
start on a sad note but i think it's
important to remember this man he was
such a great man he was the first black
secretary of the army appointed by
president jimmy carter back in
1977 alexander died on sunday at his
home in new york city he was 88 years
old he had a very long career as an
adviser to democratic presidents he
worked behind the scenes on landmark
legislation including the voting rights
act he also served as head of the equal
equal employment opportunity commission
in the 1960s when i got the news
yesterday i was so sad to hear it felt
like because i remember him so well and
i've met him uh several times he was
such a class act and his his daughter is
elizabeth alexander the acclaimed poet
and best-selling author and i was just
very sorry to hear that
we've lost another one of the greats and
you were talking earlier you said you
wanted to make a point
in your talk of the table i really did
yeah
young people too including a young army
officer named
colin powell exactly right which i just
thought was remarkable uh and longtime
supporter of president barack obama um
it's a real loss a groundbreaking figure
so too sure you have quite a legacy he
did